if you take the local food movement to
its logical extreme then you've got to
say that people who live beyond their
local food shed are essentially
parasites I am Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Pierre Durocher who's the co-author with
Hiroko Shimizu of the locavores dilemma
in praise of the 10,000 mile diet
Pierre thanks for letting me mangle your
last name all we hear about now is you
got to go direct from farm-to-table to
whatever what's good about a 10,000 mile
diet as opposed to locally grown food
well many things I mean the first
questions we asked in the book is a very
simple one I mean if everything was so
great when food when most food was
sourced locally two centuries ago why
did we go through the trouble of
developing a globalized food supply
chain in the first place
and as we point out in the book well you
know we now have more food it's more
diverse it's more affordable we're
taller we'll live longer lives we're LT
air were more food secure so really
there are only good things to say about
the 10,000 mile
but isn't the I mean don't people say
hey you know what the fact that we can
eat food from anywhere that's why we're
so damn fat well what I would respond to
that is that my wife who's iroko happens
to be Japanese and they depend more on
the global food supply chain than
anybody else and go to Japan and they're
not fatter than we are I mean ultimately
the cupcake doesn't jump into your mouth
it's up to you the globalized food
supply chain offers us more
opportunities but ultimately it's a
matter of personal responsibility I mean
people have access to more healthy food
than ever before and but they also have
access to more junk food where where
does the pushback come from in terms of
you know say I mean and the you know of
people saying okay well you should need
factory farm chicken or factory raised
vegetables
you should eat organic then when organic
because you know Walmart exactly so
zelada and then it's like no it's got to
be locally grown organic imeem Walmart
gives you fair trade coffee Walmart
gives you organic food so what's an
active is gonna do I mean what is the
lab so what are they what are what are
they after because they're not about
saying okay it's got you you got to eat
organic it's now you got to eat organic
and plus and this and that so what are
what are they drugs
to be honest there's a lot of reaction
against globalization I mean reverting
back to your tribe or your local food
chat is a one is one way to stick it to
globalization at the same time there's a
lot of romanticism going on about this I
mean I was raised in the countryside for
me producing food is a job but for a lot
of suburban and urban kids well you know
you put the seed in the ground so many
or it grows oh wow you know the miracle
of life so I suspect there's a lot of
knifed in that respect
and also a profound misunderstanding of
the problems inherent to a local food
supply a limitation and what I mean by
that is that historically people would
starve and be malnourished because they
did not have access to the surplus of
regions that had good years so typically
too bad artists in a row and you would
have a famine famine only disappear
really with the railroads and the steam
ships that allowed to move huge
quantities of food from regions that had
good years to regions that had bad years
what is the what's the role of kind of
localism you know or protectionism
really and it I mean it would be termed
in a different debate how is that how
was that driving food bands and whatnot
I mean in places like your city you've
got the size of cups you know yeah you
know soda cups and things like that
foie gras has production and sales have
been ban in California what what's going
on with that and how does it fit into
homes of your book well the team of the
book I mean it's well it's really I mean
I met reason so like I said the theme of
the book is really freedom it's really
freedom to choose and freedom to buy
where you want to buy from freedom to
source the food and where you want to
source it from I don't know I guess a
lot of politicians need to keep busy a
lot of activists now focus on food
because people feel disconnected with it
somehow they don't care where their high
pad is coming from they don't care where
the software that allows them to connect
local farmers and local consumers
through so-called Community Supported
Agriculture comes from but the fact that
we feel it that we put food into our
bodies as always at an emotional
reaction to it and at the same time it
was led by people in places like
Berkeley which have enormous year-round
supply of local foods of course you can
try to stick it to the man and Berkeley
doing it that way but exporting it to
Buffalo or Toronto where I'm from or
Quebec just doesn't make any sense
how did you get interested in this I
mean you tell a great story at the very
beginning of the book about how right
chef Jacques
and left literary studies because he
wasn't allowed to write about food and
there you know for America
chutzpah talks my very PhD in literature
proposal was turned down because food
was too pedestrian I guess but of course
if you take the local food movement to
its logical extreme then you've got to
say that people who live beyond their
local food shed are essentially
parasites and that's how I got dragged a
sort of kicking and screaming into this
whole debate because 0ko my co-author
and wife and I attended a talk a few
years ago from given from a very
prominent Canadian environmental studies
professor who argued that the Japanese
were the most parasitical people on
earth because they import more food than
anybody else on a per capita basis and
Iroko of course being treated as an
economics was like well we don't have
land to grow the food we specialized in
something else we don't ask for charity
we pay for our food why are we labeled
parasites and so the book again is an
attempt to bring in some basic economic
logic and argument about freedoms and to
essentially sing the praise of the
globalized food supply chain well it
certainly does that pierre de chez the
co-author with Hiroko Shimizu of the
locavores dilemma in praise of the ten
thousand mile diet thanks so much for
talking it's writing for raisin TV I'm
Nicolas Lee